so when you're running I noticed when
you're running for but the first thing
you have to do is put out the book the
book it's de rigueur you got to put out
that bed pablum book so we got a hold of
some of these books that all the
candidates are putting out but what you
don't know is that and we hacked into
their emails
there's always an earlier draft for the
title for example Mike Huckabee has a
book I swear to God it's called God's
guns grits and gravy that's real but the
original title was vote for me sister
these are the real titles Marco Rubio's
book is called American Dreams restoring
economic opportunity for everyone
the original title Hispanic but not too
much uh Rick Perry has a book fed up our
fight to save America from Washington
original title Bush for dummies
government always wrong
Rand Paul has a book taking a stand
moving beyond partisan politics to unite
America original title my dad without
the crazy part jeb bush's book
immigration war is forging an american
solution it sure beats bush 3 because
dad wants our name cleared before he
died um now you may not be familiar ben
Carson is yes he's the African American
neurosurgeon and Tea Party quack ooh I
think he's second in the polls now well
he has a book out called One Nation but
we can all do to save America's future
original title one of the good ones the
story of the black doctor who is not the
black doctor who killed Michael Jackson
repellent has a book America by heart
reflections on family faith and flags
she left out fetuses original titled hey
sucker yeah she doesn't even try Mitt
Romney's book no apology believe in
America a little more inspiring then
what do I have to do to be President
suck your dick okay I'll do it
and Donald Trump has a book think big
make it happen business and business in
life better than the working title me
want banana inside the mind and a half
you can have orangutan billionaire oh go
show me again